cette année exceptionnellement et à
raison de la 66e édition du festival de
cannes le jury a tenu à remettre un prix
spécial pour émettre ses prix j'appelle
monsieur oui optimiste
[Applaudissements]
annoncé déjà les dire quelque chose
j'avais commencé à parler mais c'est à
vous monsieur le président de parler de
ce prix spécial
je ne veux pas vous couper l'herbe sous
le pied non je vais juste me contenter
de dire les prix des soixante dixième
anniversaire des call est attribué
nicole kidman
[Applaudissements]
nicole malheureusement ne pouvaient être
des nôtres ce soir je vais accepter ce
prix en seulement si elle devait dire
quelque chose je leur ai dit quelque
chose comme ça
[Applaudissements]
heureusement il s'est envoyé une vidéo
est à pouvoir le faire elle-même cannes
je suis vraiment triste de ne pas
pouvoir être avec vous aujourd'hui mais
je suis ravi de recevoir ce prix là je
vous parle de nashville à intéresser
toute l'expérience de la semaine
dernière vraiment c'était comme un rêve
c'est une très belle façon de revenir
dans ce rêve je veux remercier le jury
mené par pedro merci du fond du coeur de
me faire cet honneur mon fils mon
travail et je suis vraiment je me sens
bénie de faire ce travail
je suis extrêmement reconnaissante à
yorgos lanthimos sofia coppola et jane
campion and tools les réalisateurs avec
qui j'ai travaillé qui ont cru en moi et
je veux également remercier
oui le festival merci au festival
d'exister merci à tirer à pierre et
merci de m'avoir un plus dans cette
histoire fut tant d'années regardez donc
l'anniversaire le 70e anniversaire
l'autre soir c'était incroyable voir
toutes ces légendes
c'était la fête du cinéma et des
histoires donc pouvoir faire partie de
cela mais je vous en suis très
reconnaissante
je suis tellement triste de ne pas
pouvoir être avec vous mais bon c'est
ainsi je suis avec ma famille et bonsoir
je t'aime merci beaucoup
un dauphin ainsi hogan
j'espère à très bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien que nichols être des nôtres soir
je crois que quand même il faut prendre
un foutoir
[Applaudissements]